a lesson that I learned when I was on
Rogan's show and I memed it into Rogan's
value difficulty conflation look at the
car he's driving look at the watch he's
wearing look at the girl he's with
that's unattainable to many people so it
seems like it's valuable but then you
attained it and you realized oh this
isn't valuable this is just difficult to
get and there's a difference there's a
big difference what's valuable is
something that fulfills you
intellectually emotionally spiritually
lovingly most smart people realize that
there is value in stepping outside of
their comfort and on the other side of
discomfort is something valuable we're
told that worthwhile things are
difficult to attain because if they
weren't difficult to attain they
wouldn't be worthwhile and this is how
non-valuable but difficult things get
slipped into our desires without us
noticing attaining something worthwhile
is often going to be difficult but just
because it's difficult doesn't mean it's
worthwhile